genau das ist die baby hier zusammen
schach spielen baby luca du musst nicht
überlegen sie ist weg gegangen
ok hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video auf youtube laden immer mehr leute
sims 4 gameplays hoch was soll uns gar
nicht steuern meine damen und herren wir
haben unklar
der direkt wieder am computer sitzt das
hier für die heutige folge ist es ihr
seht ihr luca ist hier relativ alleine
denkt nur an seine nancy wo ist die
eigentlich ist aber auch egal wo die ist
denn luca finde ich brauchte einen
schwanz den haben nämlich bisher nur im
garten und wie kriegt werden schwanz
genau wie man es soll nicht um schwänze
gehen heute im kreis alleine hier in
seiner fetten villa und das ist ein
bisschen das problem und deswegen hab
ich mir gedacht dass wir uns heute
einfach einen mitbewohner erstellen und
ihr seht schon im titel wer es sein wird
wir kriegen einfach mal hier oben auf
welten verwalten nur zu welt verwalten
gehen mit dem mikrofon kannst du deine
komme die fähigkeit trainieren geil
comedy ist aber nicht vorhanden bei
ducati jetzt können wir hier oben
einfach auf die haushalts verwaltung
klicken klicken hier draufklicken hier
auf diesem stift bekommen jetzt quasi
wieder im ladebildschirm angezeigt jetzt
kommen wir unten auf dem neuen systems
erstellen klicken und zwar 19 hinzufügen
das ist die bibliothek passgenauer
wir wollen heute nämlich baby erstellt
ihr seht schon im titel eingeblendet das
heißt wir machen hier sie mal als tina
ist luca eigentlich auch ein teenager
ihre stimme soll genauso rede baby
stewie palace ja dass das das trifft es
relativ gut machen wir erstmal ihr
gesicht ich finde dass die schon so ein
bisschen aus die hautfarbe die ist ja
relativ blass das heißt wir machen
obwohl es die blass wie viel das hier
sehen sollte es geht überhaupt nicht
gegen dich das ist ja alles hier nur
spaß größtenteils die haare müssen
natürlich blond sein oder eher
sonnenjahr genauer so sind die haare
die haare sind dann auch egal bei freute
sich alles gleich aus zwei den zähnen
würde ich sagen machen wir ja dass das
so lassen wir das gesicht ziehen wir
hier noch so ein bisschen weiter
zusammen dass sie noch so ein bisschen
weiter hier hin
what the [ __ ] ich wusste gar nicht dass
man das ja alles machen kann
genau das ist die baby 2000 jahre später
2000 jahre sind vergangen meine damen
und herren ich habe mich in die tiefsten
welten von sims 4 gestürzt um babys
beauty playoffs zu kreieren
ja die sieht genau so aus wir haben
jetzt in dem haushalt pizza luca und
bianca heinicke deswegen würde ich sagen
klingt mir jetzt einfach mal aufspielen
und schau mal ob die beiden sich
verstehen das übrigens mal ein leichter
wenn ich öfter sims 4 hochladen soll ich
hatte jetzt in letzter zeit nicht so
lust das hochzuladen weil sehr viele
andere youtuber das derzeit hochladen
und ich dann nicht mehr auch das
hochladen bei der hay lasten like darin
schreibt sms hier die kommentare wenn
luca steht hier noch immer in seiner
komischen kaffee tee es nur die masche
aber egal babysitter schauen wohin geht
sie setzt sich natürlich direkt an den
computer um ihre videos zu schneiden
oder um tetris zu spielen mein gott
bibiana man kennt das sieht relativ easy
aus die so kennen dahin eigentlich leute
bei uns durch den garten laufen alter
was geht ab oder haben wir auch wir
haben
dass ich jetzt ist das video soll ein
park haben wir brauchen doch eigentlich
mal ein paar nachbarn hier zieht
irgendwie keiner hin ich weiß gar nicht
was hier abgeht haushalt aus der galle
oft wollen verbindungen also ich kann
jetzt hier einfach haushalte einziehen
lassen alter wie geil ist das denn nicht
sagen
genießen sie schlecht war das aber wir
wollen uns hier nicht um familie
nächsten kümmern sondern tatsächlich um
luca und bibi und die nähren sich gerade
zum ersten mal an bzw ducato erstmal
wieder ab die wie ich würde sagen ich
stehe jetzt mal dich hier bianca einige
und du gehst jetzt mal zu luca hin und
ihr lernt euch jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen kennen die janka keine kinder
hat sich lukas ist übrigens mit eurer
sonst die letzte hier los ich würde
sagen wir verfolgen weil das gespräch
von denen bisschen das ja lustig haben
darüber gar nichts geredet hey guck mal
ich mag alpakas das kennst du vielleicht
wenn du meine videos baby die mag ich
total gerne müll befindet sich gerade
bei uns in der toilette sowie die
aussieht ich habe gerade am computer
gesetzt tetris gespielt beziehungsweise
an ich muss er die wir reden jetzt ein
bisschen fastfood gerät erhält wird wird
das volk in essen mit einem panzer an
mcdrive rosig aus mich noch nie gesehen
hast ja so sehe ich aus wie falls du
mich noch nie gesehen hast genau ich
mache auf meinem kanal gern gaming spiel
zum beispiel gern sims oder irgendwie so
jetzt verpasse ich mich luca wo gehst du
hin dieser verfressene spaßt alter der
macht sich schon wieder irgendwas zu
essen als baby ist ja so ein ehrenhafter
mensch guckt euch das an die geht
einfach zur toilette und schrubbt die
ein baby
man sieht sogar im spiegel wie sie putzt
hat muss ich hier wirklich lassen
baby baby baby baby palace unter klo
putzen wir werden das ziel sei was geht
eine ewigkeit später ja das macht echt
super baby er mich darauf die toilette
ist auch langsamer sauber level 3 der
käuflichkeit erreicht luca la hengst
luca trat da vorne zu janka hin setzt
sich mit an den tisch und die beiden
werden jetzt
hier zusammen schach spielen die
blockade muss nicht überlegen sie
weggegangen video setze jetzt verdammt
noch mal hier hin und spielt mit lukasz
ahmed oder wo willst du will kann in
diesem haushalt bei ihr keiner was
machen außer essen
definitiv nein was ist denn los mit
diesen leuten hier kommen baby jetzt
setzt sich mal hier an den tisch leben
zu luca genau so und jetzt beobachten
wir mal wieder die unterhaltung sich
fragt nicht ob man mit einer lupe
fragezeichen beobachten kann
das führt mich echt interessieren dass
hahn radja genauen zahnrad dass die sind
sinnvoll für unsere heutige gesellschaft
genau zahnräder und und blieben auch
wichtig genau genug und und bringen und
bringen 14 ja genau drin und fern das
können viele nicht weit sehen die bier
und ohne brille kann man hier in london
sprach und schach und libyen unterhalten
total bescheuert in der tat wie lange
dauert so ein scheiß schachspiel bei
denen überhaupt können jetzt mal so ein
bisschen hier kann man die zeit die ist
passiert was habt ihr keine anderen
spiele oder so ich will dass die beiden
irgendwas macht alter ihr sollt einfach
luca bianca hier ein bisschen verspielt
herumschwimmen luca kann hier auch immer
hierhin schwimmen soll das heißt die
beiden gehen jetzt mal hierhin beide in
den pool und spa und mensch seid ihr
zwei vollidioten spritzen luca kann
bianca anspritzen alter was geht denn ab
freunde ich spule die zeit seit 23
stunden hier schon vor und die beiden
schönen aber ein gott endlich sind so
vielfältig mal mit schwimmen ich würde
sagen wir machen jetzt ein schönes
barbecue mit baby soll der lukas steht
natürlich am grill sowie männer das
machen die bibi fängt natürlich wieder
unterhaltung an
ich würde sagen wir beobachten weil
wieder die unterhaltung ja hab ich das
nicht gut gekocht hier sonst wenig
bürger die nicht auf dem tisch habe
genau das ist nicht so ein fast food was
du sonst immer ist baby das ist sogar
echt lecker hier
wie schmeckt dir das ist mein gesicht
genau auf deinen kanal ja das ist ja
schön sehr gerne skulpturen auf meinem
youtube-kanal hamburger geflogen weil
ich verdient so viel geld mit meinen
produkten und er ich habe noch eine
kleine produkte zu hause weil mir noch
im schrank
also wenn du jetzt haben bild umhänge
stolze titel hätte ich richtig gehören
es sieht ja ähnlich
weil dadurch eine tiefe stimme hier
stimmt doch gar daran hier ein hotdog
gerade riecht auch relativ gut es freut
mich ja ich würde sagen während die
beiden essen schauen wir uns mal ein
bisschen noch hier um in unserer welt
wenn wir noch so alles haben hier vorne
läuft ein typ her
mal schauen wie der heißt das ist ein
junger und zwar heißt der grob
vorstellen ich muss los danke dass du
die zeit genommen hat halt deine scheiss
fresse alter ich war nicht mal bei dir
aber wir haben jetzt zum glück noch baby
und luca warum sagst du denn sowas baby
ich will nicht sterben ich würde dadurch
sagen dass ich das gemacht habe werde
ich wunderschöne toilette und da kommt
die bi an und wird erstmal sich schön
dort hinsetzen und ok oh mein gott meine
damen und herren luca hat sich vorne ins
bett gelegt
die bianca schmidt sich noch eben ab
natürlich mit blue mit was auch sonst
und sie wanderten mit zu luca ins bett
meine damen und herren was geht hier ab
freunde ok biancas ist hier fordern mich
interessiert was die fünf schlafanzug
hat wie du denkst hatte martin trockel
nachdem du auf dem fuß vorleger hier
geschlafen hast wieso legst du dich
überhaupt nicht zu luca ins bett alter
was soll denn das hier kommen schlafen
hier kommen jetzt links maria in lucca
wieso steht wieso hast du ein herz so
die beiden was geht jetzt ab alter was
wollt ihr machen wollte
mir geht das ehrlich gesagt hat so ein
bisschen zu weit
ich bin sooo heiss für die sonne luca da
kanns echt nix machen ja ich habe ja
schon eine büchern gelesen dass du
relativ heiß sein sollst liebe bier und
auch in paketen da hab ich mir nicht
extra bücher bespielt die sonne die
jetzt neben schluss zu heiß wie ich und
du siehst halten nicht so heiß aus wie
die sonne also meine damen und herren
was wir in dieser heutigen folge
geschafft haben bisher
wir haben bianca wenig
stellt und sie ist bei uns in den
haushalt eingezogen wenn ihr das nice
findet
das lassen wir unlike da wir beobachten
jetzt noch mal was hier gerade abgeht
luca läuft gerade auf toilette und geht
es ist vor allem einfach 3 uhr 54 alter
wo wollt ihr nicht einfach mal schlafen
kinder beiden befinden sich jetzt gerade
wieder im schlafzimmer ich verstehe
einfach nicht wieso die beiden hätten
sie einfach mal schlafen gehen das wäre
euch am sinnvollsten begegneten ausflug
aufs bett wie die habe ich schon gemacht
wenn wir machen hier bei luca mal die
toilette weg und das unterhalten mit
bibi und jetzt sind die beiden glaube
ich endlich mal im bett lukas kann doch
nicht so schwierig sei nicht einfach die
neben baby ins bett zu legen kommt das
muss man doch wohl hinkriegen ja setzt
sich dahinter was habt ihr mit euren
scheiß hocker da eigentlich das was
jetzt hier familie meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat das
gerne man leichter wenn ihr öfters
wollte das nicht sims hochladen wenn
jetzt öfters wollt also wenn ihr wollt
dass ich öfter hochladen meine ich in
der nächsten folge wären wir uns dann so
ein bisschen darum kümmern dass die
beiden sich vielleicht noch ein bisschen
näher kommen
vielleicht stelle ich auch noch in
weiteren zimmer also wenn ihr andere
youtuber denkt der eventuell hier noch
mit einziehen muss dann schreibt mir das
gerne kommentare und jetzt sind wir
wirklich an dem punkt des videos
angekommen meine damen und herren wo das
ganze video quasi seinen höhepunkt hat
und zwar das ende
das war so das war's jetzt ihr vom video
hier können jetzt jemanden kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
ausschenken ihr findet ihr zwei andere
videos und managen abonnent seid könnt
ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]